we don't speak to everyone in our lives
in the exact same way we speak to our
bosses to customers into strangers quite
formally and we speak to our friends and
family more casually we convey different
aspects of ourselves through our speech
and so we change our way of speaking
depending on the identity that we're
trying to project we do it for the most
part unconsciously and through history
getting it wrong could result in
anything from slight awkwardness to
death depending on how badly you
misjudged speech and exactly who you
were talking to at the time what we say
and how we say it
matters but registers aren't just for
spoken language they apply to the
written word too now there are people
who believe all writing on the internet
should follow the same standards as a
business email but chatting to a friend
is very different to emailing your boss
and the way we write reflects that our
online voice can have a wide variety of
tones and especially for folks who grew
up with the internet the neat convey
tone means that there are very well
agreed-upon conventions in standard
written English capital letters don't
convey much actual information they just
show proper nouns and the beginning of
sentences and while that might make a
paragraph easier to read we don't flag
those up at all when we speak it's it's
not necessary so in informal
conversations those that feel like
speaking we don't need capital letters
but that means online communities could
use capitals to convey something else
that does appear in conversation tone so
all caps became shouting side note put
that text in a speech bubble and a
hand-lettered font and suddenly it's not
shouting it's just how comic books and
look context matters anyway if all caps
are shouting lowercase is calm normal
conversation remove the punctuation I
get this sort of aloof don't really care
tone that works well for deadpan humor
and irony
some people think all lowercase is lazy
but it often takes work on the part of
those typing most smartphones
autocorrect it they capitalize proper
nouns and the beginning of sentences for
you turning that off or more likely
going back and undoing that
capitalization takes effort and that
shows that it's actually
meaningful I'm not just lazy in fact the
rise of deliberate law casing for
stylistic effect coincides with the rise
of auto capitalization on smartphones
and on the other hand people will
sometimes capitalize the first letter of
words for effect that happened way
before the internet Winnie the Pooh's or
the AML used that a long long time ago
and fairly often in a way that seems
quite relatable today we can repeat
characters to convey prosody rhythm and
sound through text with me repeat
exclamation marks for more emphasis we
can use question marks not for questions
but for a rising tone that means we
might be unsure about something or that
we want to hedge our bets about what
we're suggesting maybe and reversing
that rhetorical questions can be marked
by phrasing them as a question but not
having a question mark to show that
there is no rising tub and then there's
the period or the full stop in British
English periods show falling tone which
is pronounced at the end of serious
sentences which is why so many people
perceive the period as a marker of being
very serious or angry there's a
difference between okay and okay which
is fine when everyone understands that
tone one of the most extreme examples is
on tumblr where commas instead of
periods and deliberate misspellings end
up with cry typing which depending on
who you talk to is either a way to show
emotional distress or a way to
sarcastically show emotional distress
the conventions change fairly quickly
now we don't have to laborious ly type
out text messages and old keypads see
you later doesn't appear anymore there
is no single correct way to write there
are standards and conventions and
registers for different use and all the
varieties of internet speak are just
other registers they're different
sure but they are consistent and they're
understood by those who use them just
maybe don't cry tyke to your boss if
you've ever wondered why you get ominous
passive-aggressive ellipses at the end
of text messages from usually older
people that and a lot of our tales of
internet typography are in my co-authors
new book Gretchen McCulloch because
Internet is on sale July the 23rd 2019
links are in the description